Of course, the hard part now is
I do have two different regions.
How do I actually figure
out what scale to look at?
This looks good for finding an edge
here, doesn't work for this one.
I can keep growing it.
Oh, at this point, it does.
Plus, of course, it's possible,
and a computationally and
interesting challenge if
I have to do this a lot.
The problem is how do we choose a
corresponding circles for both of them?
And of course that could be
computationally a challenging task.
We could do brute force search
methods and stuff like that.
But remember there's another
problem associated with it.
Not just the fact that I need to do
this, but the fact is that this,
the region could have other bits
of information that is not there.
So in essence me matching this to this,
I don't have the full picture there.
I just have the full
picture at this point.
So we need to kind of start thinking
about what kind of a match it
would be also.
Again, if I now start kind of zooming
out of this one let's see what happens.
Of course, all of a sudden it
was only a match at this scale,
not at the other scale when I zoom out.
So again, it's not guaranteed.
I can scale out on this one.
It matches.
But when I scale out,
no this doesn't match anymore.
So basically,
you have to choose the scale of
the best corner and stick with it.